us he is a huge prepper yeah so he does
a two-hour prep show before the three
hour show right he's very thorough he
wants to make sure he has the graphics
he wants to support what he's talking
about he wants to make sure that he has
the sound he wants to support what he's
talking about he wants to make sure he
has the statistics he's looked up you
know the historical stuff that goes
along with what he's saying he really
talks through all of the topics so his
ability to you know stretch a subjects
the way that you're talking about and
continue to have the conversation with
you the listener but by himself it's
crazy I mean his brain works differently
to be able to do that anyway but it
really also helps that he preps a lot he
doesn't like to waste air time he's very
very serious about the show he feels
like it's disrespectful to the audience
to not be prepared to do a show I love
it so that's what that's really what
makes him great and able to do such a
big show because three hours of content
in our business